it's back no not the banana phone the
other phone that curves to your face LG
is kicking off CES 2015 with the LG G
flex 2 and it's better than the previous
version in pretty much every way the
phone has a smaller 5.5 inch full HD
curved display which is much easier to
hold in one hand the curve is still very
slight like a slight smile but the big
improvements come with durability the
glass is 20% stronger that means you can
sit on it without bending it unlike this
thing oh yes it has a bunch of new
selfie tricks you can hold up your hand
like this then squeeze it and it should
set off the shutter button selfie stick
not included the back self healing
powers which can recover from light
scratches all by itself are set to be
much faster now and there's a laundry
list of improved specs it has a 64-bit
Qualcomm processor and a better 13
megapixel camera and it has the same
Android 5.0 software as the g3 which has
been nicely cleaned up I also really
like how you can peek at your
notifications right from the home screen
no word yet on us availability or
pricing but overall LG pretty much fixed
everything I complained about in the
first one which means this phone may no
longer fall flat